so Totoro key is arguably the most
naturally talented student at UA when
the series began he was presented as an
almost invincible hotshot so much so
that we were able to overlook his
terrible costume design he was one of
only four students to get into the
school via special recommendation and he
was born into a wealthy family with a
quirk there's almost the perfect
combination of both his parents
abilities however despite all these
advantages Soto's childhood was still
one of the most tragic in the series but
yet it's still likely not even the worst
in his own family endeavor really needs
to work on his parenting skills since
the beginning of the series Shoto has
grown up a lot in terms of his attitude
his quirk and his feelings towards his
dad so today I thought it'd be cool to
realistically examine how much more he
can evolve after a ten-year time skip
just before we get into it though be
sure to hit that sub button as we are
still on that yellow brick road to 100k
we're nearly there you know not too far
away so I'd really appreciate it if you
would subscribe
Todoroki was about 15 years old when
season four finished which means that
after a 10-year time skip he'd have long
finished his time at UA and would have
been a hero for quite a while now
after graduating from UA it's highly
likely that Shoto would accept his dad's
offer to join the endeavor agency as a
sidekick as by this time I reckon Soto
would have probably forgiven his father
in some capacity or at the very least
agreed to move past their differences
we've seen glimpses and hints towards
this in the anime and the manga so by
the time he graduates told surely be on
much better terms than they are right
now by joining as a sidekick endeavour
can groom Todoroki to succeed him and
take over the family business in a few
years which I guess means the endeavor
agency would be renamed into the shoto
agency what do you guys think does that
have a ring to it or no remember his
hero named for now at least is actually
just Shoto so yeah that would be what it
would be called I guess I reckon for a
few years he would act as a sidekick
until he eventually surpasses endeavor
in terms of strength and also gains
enough experience so that there's
nothing really of significance that his
dad can teach him anymore that moment
will be the signal for the big guy to
finally retire after all those years of
Pro hearing and he can finally sit back
relax you know maybe get a copy of one's
justice
- and just virtually beat up all my for
the foreseeable future at the age of 25
Shoto would have been running the agency
for a while and using his evolved quirk
to save people all across Japan we'll
get into what his quirk might look like
later in the video but for now I want to
focus on where he'd be on the hero
charts at this point I think it's
relevant to remember that endeavour
himself was second place in the charts
at only 20 years old so I'm thinking
that anything lower than second place
would be pretty lackluster given that
shota was the one who was born with even
better genetics than endeavour himself
that being said though there are
obviously some things that natural born
heroes cannot compete with and that of
course is the power of one floral
combined with the user who wants nothing
more than to save people with a massive
grin as the og protagonist I think it's
inevitable that Deku will be in that
number one spot which sadly means for
Shoto the best he's gonna do is second
place the question then becomes who
would compete with shota for that number
two spot the biggest contenders that
come to mind for me are back ago Toki
army and eNOS er although if my back ago
theory happens then here he will
definitely not be in contention
if kat-chan is truly out of the picture
then I think Shoto has a really good
chance because you know he's taken over
the agency of the former number one hero
which by itself just gives him an
advantage over everyone else because he
doesn't need to build up his reputation
or popularity in the same way and not to
mention the fact that his quirk is just
crazy flashy and cool anyway so that
second place spot does probably go to
him if back ago is not around
moving on to his relationships though in
my personal opinion I reckon that he and
Momo would definitely be a couple by
this point and don't get me wrong I'm
not saying that every parent way who has
some sort of chemistry has to get
together but for me personally I feel
like these two are one of the top three
ships in this series which have the best
chance of happening in fact not just
that I think it should happen yaya Rosie
clearly admires Haruki a lot as we saw
during the practical exams but the
feeling seems to be mutual as he not
only picked her for the cavalry battle
but also voted her for cross rep and he
just he just loves her okay I'm sure
both of their families would approve of
this relationship as they come from
similar social status and they both get
into you a via recommend
not to mention the fact that the
combination of these two choirs should
be something that should probably be
illegal it would be that powerful I
don't think they would have any kids by
this point though because they're still
in their mid-20s and if you're really
committed to being a hero I think it's
best to stay celibate like all might
does also especially for a hero having a
kid is like having a massive liability
as they will always be your weakness and
villains can potentially exploit that so
whilst I'm sure these two would be a
boss hero couple I doubt they're
overpowered kids would be around just
yet in terms of show toes own quirk how
would it improve during this 10 year
time span being the prodigy of the
Todoroki family his icy side allows him
to counter the overheating that both
endeavor and Dobby suffer from when he
was a kid endeavor said to him that he
could achieve new levels of heat by
reaching his limit and then surpassing
that again and again and again and by
the age of 25 he would comfortably reach
a level in which every flame he produces
is bright blue much like his dear evil
brother while star B has the raw
firepower I mean we've seen it endeavour
is the one who has the technique as
there were things that he did during the
pro hero art that let's be real guys we
would never see Darby do something like
this
in this sense shows who would be like
the perfect combination of these two
characters as he would have mastered
things like prominence burn and all the
different flash fire moves but with the
hotter blue flames so he can do whatever
endeavor can do but with Gabby's level
of power
I imagine that after this time shota
would have also reached a level of
enlightenment in which his icy hot quark
is no longer defined by his left or
right side he can pick and choose to use
ice or fire on any limb that he wants as
an example imagine he's shooting flames
out of the bottom of his feet
kind of like replicating endeavours
levitation and then as he's doing that
he fires out icy attacks out of both of
his hands or alternatively he could just
go all out with the flames from every
limb that he has which I guess would be
the only way to truly replicate some of
endeavours moves and yeah thinking about
it now I kind of imagine that endeavor
wouldn't really agree to retire until he
saw that show too was capable of doing
this and surpassing him in the process
on a completely random note one of my
favorite meals from
any character in the series is this
attack we're sure to refer to in the
manga as his heaven piercing ice wall I
don't know about you guys but when he
first uses in the Sports Festival
against both the robots and then again
we were showing off against Cerro those
were both draw dropping moments for me
as he was able to do all of that at just
15 years old if the circumstances
allowed for it surely the 25 world
version of this character could produce
way more ice during this movie I'm
thinking like covering a third of his
city in his eyes it would be pretty
awesome if he could push back invading
armies with just the swipe of his hand
because of one thing I've always thought
about is in the world of my heroes
surely you still have international
conflicts you know you still have war so
what if in the next generation when all
the heroes are grown up what if we see a
legit like attempted invasion of Japan
by another country and all the students
who we know now and they just have to go
out on the battlefield all across Japan
showing the full might of their quirks
maybe in a situation like that we could
see a move like this but anyway people
those are my thoughts on what time skip
turner okie could look like and be like
but for his quirk evolution I didn't
have one more thought and that was the
idea of him combining his fire and ice
to create water based attacks I mean I
think something like that might be
possible you know in the future perhaps
as always thank you for watching and
this video was a pretty special one
because we are around the one-year
anniversary of my first ever video which
is still on this channel if you want to
look at it to see how far we've come in
a year is pretty amazing and so to end
this video I'll be leaving you with a
clip from my first ever video and that
will hopefully inspire maybe some of you
to start your own channels if you've
been thinking about it but yeah I'll
leave this here and peace out I mean
that's insane
but yeah that's basically everything I
had to say about this review I wanted it
to be quite concise in terms of just a
review of the chance if the people who
couldn't be bothered to read it and I
just gave a few little opinions in there
here and there this is my first video on
this channel so please subscribe if you
want to stay up to date with the latest
videos that I'm putting out I plan to do
more trap's reviews in the future
probably some theories and maybe some
fact videos as well but I'll just see
how this video works out and you know if
anyone's really taking a liking to it I
probably will improve in the future I
know this probably wasn't the best video
in the world but like I
I just want to give a concise review of
what happened in the chapter I think I
did that but let me know if you think
there's any room for feedback I'm always
open to feedback and oh yeah thank you
for watching